ciao a tutti per evitare che questo
video riceva commenti tipo guardate che
se io vivo anche solo un goccio bene a
mente parto per la tangente sono astemia
dico subito che questo video non parlo
di astemi perché provvedini loro non
fanno nemmeno apposta è una cosa che
così penso sia di natura e non voglio
nemmeno parlare di chi fa il contrario
leggasi tutti quelli che sono ubriachi
fradici e cercano ancora di darsi un
contegno e poi non ho mai capito perché
lo facciano altri non ci sto a posto non
si all tranquillo sto luci non ha
convinto
83 sì sì sì comunque piacere comodino
veramente ti chiami simone bonomi simone
è il tuo pensiero di chiamarmi comodino
mi rivolgo infatti ai miei idoli a tutte
quelle ragazzini e geni e perché la
maggior parte sono ragazzine non veniva
10 cazzate che nascondono le loro voglie
perverse e la loro spasmodica ricerca di
attenzione dietro un mini soggetto di
vino bianco
qualora ve lo steste chiedendo gli step
per una perfetta finto piegatura sono i
seguenti 2 che chiude a chi tarsia festa
manco non si santagada il giorno di sant
agata che non so quale sia ed in un'auto
amica molto stupida mi raccomando molto
stupida tutto quello che non vorresti
mai fare ma che puntualmente non vedi
l'ora di fare beh sì per stessero deciso
di farmi mettete in cambio de mita tinte
allora ma se la marca non faremo niente
questo è impazzita anche a me toccare un
secondo solo un invito poi da quindi
misura messa un michela posto lui e
marco chi ha il marco ma poi marca poi
più piccole ditte veramente più grandi
rimedi 278 giorno non riesci sullo stage
italia ma sinceramente non so nemmeno
perché abbia queste informazioni inca
chi lo segue giorno e notte
il coniglio uscito dalla tana ottimo
smith e rapporto tra mezz'ora
a questo punto bisogna andare alla festa
a parte o quel che sia e per un mini
sorsetto di qualsiasi bevanda va bene
pure la maionese e iniziare a dire al
maggior numero di gente possibile che
non ci capite più una mazza o rigata un
po con briaca a questo punto date il
meglio di voi questa macchinetta
la corda sapeva il mondo e mi è in
questo momento sento come una cocorita
fronte a deporre un uovo se fosse una
ragazza mi tocca proprio le borracce lo
sapevo
stasera
cacchio mia madre ragazzi un attimo che
devo fare la sobria è pronto mamma si
tornò dopo mamma non mi serve le
calcolatrici per farti un calcolo facile
quanto la radice quadrata di un miliardo
274 milioni 689 mila 400 335 mila e 700
2,79 26 49 87 545 mamma tranquilla nomi
di sordi lo ricordo a memoria il mio
codice fiscale sc nk y coppia kakà
mammato riguardati che nel frattempo
tessuto alcune una sciarpetta così
quattro e quattr'otto così te la porti a
casa della metti che magari stampo di
più riguarda tomei
ciao ciao ciao ragazzi glielo proprio
fatta proprio per cose vedete questo
video non smettete di un pregarvi per
finta perché io amo che sembra che al
per finta giuro cioè pagherei per poter
mettere tutte queste persone dentro una
gabbia di vetro e video di sbranarsi
l'un l'altra e rapito e ricordatevi che
l'unico modo per ottenere una varia
natura vera è quello di beccarsi car
davvero e se proprio siete magari che ne
so tristi non gettatevi sull'alcol
gettatevi sulla cioccolata che meglio
ingrassa sipro almeno e meno cioè triste
podio anche la cioccolata evitate
istintivi tristi comunque tornando per
un momento seri invece lo so ora farò un
sermone però lo devo fare perché magari
è giusto che venga fatto alla fine di
questo video se bevete la sera e non
riuscite a guidare perché magari siete
già delle pippe di vostro a guidare
evitate di guidare da ubriachi ok non
c'entra niente la multa che ti fa il
vigile se riuscite a beccarlo sullo
share beccarla nemmeno 109 le cose tipo
se beve non guida nel ecco vorrei che
nessuno di voi fosse il prossimo
assassino che investono coppietta di
giovani innamorati sul motorino perché
si sentiva superman a me ha bevuto e
pensava di poter guidare invece alla
fine finisce che si spappola sul cemento
e li ammazza così a 19 anni
capito pensavi che facciamo guidare
l'amico e non succede nulla
il famoso amico sobrio se ce n'è uno
altrimenti prendetevi il tempo nessuno
cioè avete fatto le quattro fino a bene
potete pure fare le sette derby dei
fiori macchina o ci sono quelle del tipo
telefono amico comunque evitiamo di
ucciderci no